je ne savais pas si c'était bien ou pas
ce qui se passe et je sentais comme un
truc pas normal mais quand on n'a pas de
repères quand on a 7 ans 8 ans 9 ans 10
ans ben on se laisse faire et puis on on
se tait puis on est reçu par les
sénateurs la psychiatre muriel salmona
explique les conséquences à l'âge adulte
des violences sexuelles subis dans
l'enfance c'est le premier facteur de
risque de mortalité précoce de décès
précoce premier facteur de risque de
suicides de dépressions répétition de
conduites addictives premier facteur de
risque d'obésité troubles alimentaires
de troubles cardiovasculaires
nous devons protéger les enfants et si
ce n'est pas écrit dans la loi c'est
notre rôle de législateur d'écrire à
seuil
senna en action c'est sur public sénat